il conteste sa révocation pour alexandre
langlois s'est présenté devant le
tribunal de grande instance de paris ce
vendredi le secrétaire général du
syndicat vigie police révoqué de la
police en mars dernier pour avoir
offensé sa hiérarchie il s'en était pris
dans des tracts à l'ancien patron de la
police nationale le ministère de
l'intérieur avait décidé de le
sanctionner lourdement et de façon
inédite s'agissant d'un responsable d'un
syndicat le verdict sera rendu le 5
novembre alexandre l'emploi militent
pour une rupture conventionnelle qu'on
lui refuse sa direction
qui est reproché par le ministère public
je lirai par la police nationale en
disant bas les policiers sont
responsables des cadres légaux et des
méthodes d'utilisation de la police est
ce que le syndicat vigie a voulu mettre
en avant et en exergue c'est exactement
la verse c'est qu'on est il ya un cadre
légal on doit le respecter par contre
est-ce que ce cadre légal et légitime on
a utilisé une image choc pour
interpeller les personnes ce qui a été
l'objectif a été atteint vu qu'on a été
retweeté les gens ont pu partager le
contenu du tract comme a pu le relater
la presse par contre quand c'est un
membre du gouvernement qui tètent le
peuple français de peste brune dans les
rues ça ne pose pas de problème alors
peut-être qu'il avait une phrase
provocateur il a voulu amplifier sa
rhétorique mais du coup si la loi n'est
pas la même pour tout le monde ça pose
des questions également donc le tribunal
va devoir juger de tout ça on espère
qu'il comprendra le but de la démarche
pourra améliorer nos institutions et pas
laisser certaines personnes j'ai voulu
abuser de leur pouvoir de petits chefs